teller sold for hip-hop rose 92 3-yard
he knows thriller after parties who leg
calves rate Sinatra my brother DJ damage
on brother man low a yachty is back in
LA what's up bro hello sup yachters
how you feeling man they're tired why
are you tired what he's been doing pie
travelling I've been asleep yeah how
many days three three days and you don't
do drugs
so that can only imagine any any a three
hour where's the 5-hour energies
involved you know how do you keep stay
up honestly I'm really not away right
now we could tell give my adderall they
do at already get it at that's drug
that's yeah yeah a description but this
guy of Red Bull is on business anyway
man new album is coming out Friday
finally highly anticipated yeah I'm
excited you're excited man I think it's
one of the dopest album covers I've seen
in a long time and I appreciate yeah
there's never a lot of effort put into
album covers in hip hop these days so I
appreciate the message yeah I don't
think a lot of people know how hands-on
you are with a lot of the imaging and
packaging of your material bro yeah you
know a lot of people think that I'm
right the label do that
yeah well the mixtapes that was all your
vision and now both my mixtape covers
came from my craydar again okay okay but
this specific album cover on I created
like me am I created a right to do
together but I had the concept of like
know that this took like like the
message behind the cover any she gave
you a long it should be no horse
hands-on with it
exactly hmm yeah well look I got to ask
you about something because uh it just
popped up on my Instagram timeline oh
you know stop baby and offset are going
to kind of go and crazy on instance I'm
saying coming at offset super sideways
right off the graph I mean obviously
again that Sunday
first iPhone I know that your labelmate
offset baby was showing you mad love my
newfound brother so I mean obviously I
like both guys I learned booth is there
is it can you play the peacemaker
something like that can you fix me harm
to our I want to group chat man to our
just cause of it that's good
what did he say if you go he didn't
figure you gotta give it time cuz he's
clearly he did to pose into one poster
he's got food disrespectful my goodness
what is your religious views are you a
card for Christian yeah you are
Christian I'm not going on the words in
the truth okay okay it's me yeah now we
have a little debate that goes on in
here but I don't judge anybody right
because I mean I want a theist so that's
why he'll I told sigh baby I'm a guy
before that I do a judgment for them he
judges me for everything I do but really
like a really weird like a like marriage
in there I mean are we are humans out
then they're 100% men no we do have a
little debate going on here man - master
debate we be brought up all set and we
were talking about our mEagle brothers
right and or yes this is the reason i am
the only guy here we go
in this camp that we have right here to
really have to party the believes take
off is not a bad emcee that's not true
we just said he's the weakest link gotta
meetings that's what i don't agree with
do you think might take office that
office just really self Jerry you know
he's really to himself he so it's more
his image that's so he just doesn't
really care about the whole rap persona
right no China it in touches what I was
telling them a lot of the songs that
they love take off goes crazy and I just
feel like I just feel like they don't
even notice that's him going all the
girl goes crazy he just wasn't on bad
and boozy
that's the only one yeah the big hockey
the enema tear instant famous he's gotta
be sick just a little he's gotta be a
little freak no more my favorite nigo
song though pretty no more yeah that's
the one that is fire that's stuck
straight crack man but Yaya do who do
you got on the album I saw you got a
nice little nice little lineup of guys
where I talked I really wanted to be
sewed arena yeah it was just sorting
checks to hat I don't need that certain
people
um so I got watching c'mon
yeah like west coast holiday by yeah um
then a step step London and it's like
Caribbean rocky um Diplo get blows
amazing boy dip blows amazing we did we
did a check he put his record yeah
don't listen son I can't hear that is
crazy um I got my brother's van der
grüne on x-man he goes on there yeah
yeah take off so then take off on it
crazy exactly they're going crazy I
better put some respect
he says meet me I was like oh I felt
like when y'all didn't give me that
acknowledgement yeah I'm saying he
remember we said there's no link me goes
he's just he's the weakest of the fetus
at least Paula said weak girl is Lee I
won't say were you to know what to do
these [ __ ] he's the Moses up he's a
low profile but when they first came up
they the most all three went solo his
bag would be too small to do a club I
got a foursome the turn up yeah after
you should just like start banging like
a car to be like offset like he should
just find what is this already to have
more social persona I don't know let's
see if you meet him in person he's like
he's like the big he's like one of the
coolest he's hilarious hilarious he's so
funny
taking all this so so and nobody knows
that cuz he's he didn't talk just be
jealous he's so funny like yo I saw last
year I deejay on stage at a trolling
loud and that was the first time I had
like heard of you and on my way I was
driving from Tampa to Miami I was the
first time I ever heard one night in a
Minnesota and I'm not gonna lie I had no
idea what I was I was like what the [ __ ]
is this hmm you know I'm not what what
some might call the whole day thirty
years old okay but yeah what do you
consider oh hey I remember you said
anybody kind of over like 27 yeah I'm an
old head man so uh we're also I thought
I was young
age or is it like a thought these old
[ __ ] is an imitator descendants it's a
agent mentalities knowledge I was going
to say damn I gotta balance the mixer
the first time I ever heard your music
and I get reminded me of like you really
reminded me of I love Makonnen at first
okay you probably heard that a lot early
did you I love a little bit but then I
saw you perform and I was like maybe
these kids is it's it's crazy but the
same day someone told me that you didn't
drink or do drugs and in like that
landscape of hip-hop artists that you're
running with right now everyone's on
pill every day
Oh opiate it's heroin lien is really
here name it without some people so that
was like the first I was like you know
what man I upper so I'm not mad at
anybody getting their money but um but I
found that to be like that's commendable
in today's world our music man so I
respect you for that you're my son's
favorite rapper to shout out Aiden
maskull are big shots are blatant but
obviously he's 11 okay yeah yeah yeah
young man you go arm up in the yachty in
the width on the way back then if I told
you how many times I heard one night or
I Spy my car listen it's crazy but I was
going to ask you like is it is it hard
to like I mean I'm sure peer pressure's
like a [ __ ] man we talked about
teenage emotions like mm not not not um
not really
peer pressure is more so like sexuality
Contin which obviously we all do not
Jackson I'm like I just like it's not
even in my dog
so having sex without condoms is not
even in yourself no no haven't I'm sure
he had money aside we thought house
drugs well he says I was trying to
understand analogy I was like right he
was saying professors like trover like
yo cuz you know have you broken up a lot
of artists yeah I doesn't really good to
me I'm saying prayers for me is probably
like sex without account okay no way
you're telling me a whiz is smoking he
had you to general you gonna say no I
was like a dark like two tours will not
be able to remake out reverse for the
remix it up that I already will play
before me any issue of verse and I made
a reference to pull up records yeah me
audited hand smoke you you probably
getting a little buzzed anything I did
it interview it
new dog he wanted nice man and you
didn't want me buddy asked me and you
didn't smoke nah don't send any nasty
I'm [ __ ] smoking that died
perspective man Steven that's a big deal
man
and I saw the Vice land man and then
your parents and like I was like yo it
baby like I I'm a Joe Budden fan I spoke
with slaughterhouse but when I watch
that interview like this dude's a
[ __ ]
for like no good reason like that's what
the old head mentality kicks in like
that was like next-level poster child oh
hey man I think the issue overall is
people are understanding where the same
is coming from because I see no yachty
being low yachting for the music bard
the music he's always like oh I'm sure
my god I'm sorry but I mean seeing
people tag might even hear the music yet
right so clearly there's already star
power people were just waiting for the
music he had something bigger and my in
my view so if you're not a fan and
you're not watching what's going on in
the temperature of what's happening
you're not gonna get it yeah I mean
clearly Nauticus seen the potential that
argot seem to put nautical smart man
how'd you land that not a Karnataka was
not in a water you know the fire will
boat a resurrected all Monica like I
remember that my not there was a notic
event at one point too for those people
who don't know there was a notic event
yeah very good question man I was just
now I kept tagging them and my pictures
and they finally he said wake up got
caught with of it yeah you know when you
do a song like the record would see
grizzly where you're kind of snapping on
them do today yeah from the D to the a
is that that's like out of your comfort
zone to do something like that no not at
all ah I'm curious because like when you
wrap it on the it sounds like at times
your offbeat if I'm saying that's just
better like I should think this offbeat
like flow free way it used to be offbeat
a lot back in the disco smell like just
like my way but like I don't know I'm I
did that song we I'm just just like to
show people that I can I do that's just
not my thing you know when people try
really try to like get out of their Lane
this when you start crashing that's
really I feel know like that's the one
thing I could say about you I don't know
if it's a good or bad
I think but I feel like you try to like
please sir they're like for example
freestyle into the Ebro thing like
that's something you really they have to
do and that's not and that you know it
would I think that's what it is with all
my learning and small learning were like
as I get deeper into this I realize that
I don't have to please everybody now you
got go always shot I did it I did that
John please run just to try to please
Ebro you know like I didn't have to do
that and I don't have to like I don't
know so I'm just as I'm growing up and
I'm maturing music and I'm so new to
everything I'm just starting to you know
experience you learn you how to say no a
little bit late right I think it's good
cause it shows the appreciation bro like
you know did a lot of people be scared
to do it you know you did it you push
yourself out there you're not afraid to
put yourself out there but I'm sorry oh
no I didn't have to do that Joe Budden
show but he exactly I went because he
was taught you know I saw he was talking
crazy about me I wanted any views and
I'm saying I have to have morning off to
sleep in you know but I just slept in
when you were going to act six a second
I gotta go I gotta go I had to you know
I got to have this conversation because
you gotta respect he was just judge me
before he knew me you know he didn't
know anything about me you just make an
audit assumptions no and so I have to go
in there and face to face that but I'm
so sorry when I did that ii l
interviewee bro I'm sorry I said that up
but I don't know most of my controversy
injuries I said oh it seems like you
have like like like a lot of this hate
you get you carry that chip on your
shoulder and you you know you're
motivated to prove some people own yeah
that's like nothing like uh because I
just feel like a lot of people just hate
me for no reason it's not reason to now
I'm gonna say this I tweeted this all
true recently I said now because you are
the most polarizing figure in all of
hip-hop
you are the Donald Trump of rap in my
opinions the Donald Roman have to say
that you're racist you're not ready but
you're not everyone it Donald Trump but
but but there's people that [ __ ] look
down here would I love Donald Trump
you're terrible rednecks who had no bro
I don't think you like that convey no
but you know that's just like when
Charlemagne
you know he's each out to say I was the
poster child for wack rappers and and it
didn't hit me when he said it but it
wasn't so I guess after when I went home
and like saw the internet how like that
how they were like responding to it and
it's just kind of like when I sweeted
that I just meant like you're like
Donald Trump's a very polarizing figure
like why the [ __ ] hate his guts and
they have good well I don't think people
have good reason to hate your goods so
no you're the Tim Tebow of rap how about
that the biggest people just don't try
to invent any time once you come to know
I've been Tebow a local college water
Tim Tebow for no reason 19 Kendrick Jake
oh great they're the episode hit while
right now right right he's 10 years
younger than okay well there's an age
gap and people really not understanding
were talking about
fully appears on what they really like
you guys we all in the right but that's
not me and I think that's well I think
that you know I think that's the whole
big gap that a lot of people don't get
no a lot of people forget that I'm 19
that I just graduated high school two
years ago people love to hate things I
graduated high school in 2005 almost a
she follows and like give grade the old
her we're only asking you were in fifth
grade when 50 cent was popping that's
great I wasn't so good out of our
partner know so who would you listen to
at that age who really lured yadi and
5th grader with all sorts were also from
my from my memory I believe your pops
was wearing a dead prez t-shirt your
mother photographer that's crazy I was
going to ask you that friend is like
what most people will consider like a
penny of real rats my dad loves yeah
he's super political stick I'm making em
one and so that's why I was going to ask
you like it seems like your pops is kind
of a an old head yeah my dad a well
books to my dad is musically driven
every way my dad loves rock music you
jazz that's where I get all my melodies
from so you grew up though around that
yeah about that my dad used to play he
used to play all that I used to play
dead prez used to play jay-z Young Jeezy
but my dad used to play stuff like DJ
Dylan J Dilla J Dilla here's the player
needs to play a lot of Coldplay go Tom a
lot of John John Mayer no John Mayer
John Lennon John Legend author John
Silver Joe Joe John like that my dad
played a Danger Mouse Alaia my dad
played all did you ever hear that did
you dad ever play the MF DOOM Danger
Mouse album danger doom you ever heard
that's a real specific - played engine
all Star Wars oh yeah that's good [ __ ]
Danger Mouse one of my favorite
producers of all time he's amazing
so you see that's tell me so I think I
think a lot of people who don't like
know that about you like that you come
from honestly I don't think they care
and they don't take time I want to see
the negative this I don't know where you
know it's unfortunate about like that
that incident I had you know that the
dude to begin to talk really just shaped
people's mindsets stuff and it's
unfortunate but Yolo let's talk about
some fortunate well listen he was on
Forbes 30 under 30
yes that's a big look big deal he got
the the new what is that is that a hotel
on your name Jim grand Tigers here this
is good money tiger so III mean that
that I'm assuming is whatever those are
all diamonds yeah of course Jesus can
you show it off with a camera we are in
this your newest piece
nah my god piece so guys becoming
conscious it should be everybody into
the week I'm at who made it uh John's
name is John Gaiden it's Loki jewel in
Atlanta I'm not really a heart of flesh
I feel you really talking though it's
super popping my way to use here so when
you were a kid you got to like meet did
you ever meet a press at all times go do
I just go stick shots all the time
that's crazy man how does your pops know
dead friends talk is their personal hard
one I got used to do photographer a
little john-john let let legend uh
constant or so
I can't wait we don't know Tatum here
that's when the damage is taught with
five or ten South are they volunteers
the disaster man yeah man Detroit ever
ever influenced you at all
did you ever I don't know okay okay good
job he's 19
the answer the question I'm 27 of course
it was influenced me that's an older guy
what are you really into like because
obviously right now everyone's talking
about Kendricks out damn that's
something that you're that you have in
rotation what do you got rotation man oh
I had in rotation um I like Frank Ocean
Frank Ocean is yeah I was still
listening Coldplay's go stories out of
them a lot I've been listening to my
album watch trying to make sure trying
to see it listen to it another I could
other ear said basically yeah Charlie's
told other assets like I'm trying to be
somebody else listen tonight okay get
two different perspectives yeah what's
your favorite movie whistle yadi
favorite movie ah it's between um master
disguise or do the right thing or the
Warriors it's master disguise the one
with the little small what's the hard
one ask them to do from Wayne's World
yeah yeah yeah the coordinated Carvey
yeah he's not nervous have you opened up
your food pilot yet because before it
was just pizza pepperoni pizza it is
you're still just [ __ ] it up with the
pizza huh yeah that's right phrase it's
Pisa and waffles with bacon what's your
favorite pizza spot Oh Papa John's
that's it like you don't have like we
got it yo and Buzz the garlic butter
sauce puts Papa John's over the top
though a lot of people try to downplay
it cuz it's commercial pizza but it's
amazing a great still pizza every day
yeah and waffles that's it not it but
basic basics my favorite restaurant
right now is cookout no that isn't it so
a fast food um this is your debut album
you've had a successful mixtapes out
it's obviously a big moment there's so
much like you said man you're the
probably the most like top two or three
talked about dudes in the rap game
whether it's positive negative you have
to do food you feel the pressure of
putting out you know the first project
the pressure is on you guys like you
said you you you enjoy proving a lot of
these haters wrong yeah but it's like a
teenage trippin album so like hopefully
I'm just uh but I just hope that it it
it's understood that it's for teenagers
like if people go in and with like
mindset of this being like music for
like a four-year-old like it's not for
that you know I'm saying for kids trying
to figure themselves out and going
through it not growing struggles and
stuff like that so it's not for a
husband with a wife into three sons
not for me clearly I guess not for me I
was young this whole time but it might
have yeah as a couple hits or the bumper
saying you can't it just depends on your
mindset you know right people of clothes
mindset yeah you know some people go go
through life only one to hear certain
things you know some people don't want
to hear singing hip-hop that's true
you know like people some people cringe
at the fact that a lot of times you
think yeah I mean but but I mean I mean
all the people that cringe at that like
you know kind of like a lot of people
those people be Kanye fans and Connie
has a whole [ __ ] out it's the people
to say mumble rap and you got a job I
know that one time J try to kill the
auto-tune work
yeah thanks see more people downloaded
it yeah yo but what's crazy is is the
mumble rap thing like it like we was
talking about this like I don't think
you mumble much I don't mumble at all
it's crazy but I'm the like the face of
it you are the face of mumble rapid
we're like it's like you and like yet we
also talked about this little movie
don't mumble
yeah well [ __ ] ain't anything
bubble wrap to I am afraid if anybody so
humble rap I think little Wayne was the
first three Wayne was a mumbling [ __ ]
[ __ ] future on purpose you cannot like a
lot of like that was a lean way I mean
he is a he's the mumbles not making
sounds like you know he was the he was
that guy hmm
yells now I think about who does mom
they just saying it little Dirk said
that future is the
the New Age to POC would you care to
comment on that I don't know I don't
know like that I could maybe say twins
now I have so learned my lesson that
shake them alone what explain it would
you just put it out there did you have a
reason and later my thing is like most
people can't take a little dirt out of a
lineup so like well I like loser I like
him too but I'm saying like most people
like like I'm sure like you know Nancy
from Kansas City has no idea the [ __ ]
little Dirk is I wonder if our cameraman
Daniel knows who little Dirk is Daniel
could you point out little Dirk if we
had 10 random dudes standing in a line
of Judah do you know who look that's
crazy
Danny okay see my point of time outside
of Chicago or maybe st. Louis another
dirt I respect our regular dirt Thank
You parson thank you pot hey you I just
make that clear
you be 19 who's your Big E who's your
part being outlying tears nobody today
I'll talk about like who's somebody look
at the youngster the young generation
that you look up to the way we might
have looked up to pod biggie for example
somebody that you really Mossad soldier
boy who's one the rapper's it could be
like a Kanye somebody that y'all really
look up to like this is our generation
so we really try our because I can't
speak for the masses like I look like
you'll get your son I mean I like I like
you know the drug or strike is a
stampede straight coming kick hiding
Cuddy
good car you can even may feel like a
lot of the artists love Cuddy man we got
to it I must let the heart is like a
vault he's like an artist artist if that
makes sense that really make artists
market or no it makes perfect sense
yeah [ __ ] Coldplay maybe a little B
hey no I usually that I think that now
let me say that see that influence swag
so now I want to talk about a 1-up
Charlemagne here because if anyone is
the poster child of lack rappers it's
definitely little B see what little B
right now where is he back then even
when he was cooking and doing Ellen
DeGeneres and all that yeah
with the guy terrorism for ears yes in
my opinion but I could cook I could do
to cook addicted I'm not absolutely
generous all that [ __ ] but that [ __ ] was
terrible your [ __ ] like like I can't
even compare the two because there's at
least melody and like some yeah I can't
I came from not a little B hater but
it's not one song I will be hater I have
nobody not wonderful
I like familiar one who the pack the
pack was incredible and super is there
like his wave I think I love all his
music but more than this new that God
just loves you cook is move now of
course you can cook a discipline right
now no I can't I'm too tired notice or
else don't we know that that wall talk
is what is quack I'm trying to find it
it's got a great movement of man he was
all about positivity yes he was on the
same as you are that's where I got it
from can we ever expect to collab with
little beanie on yes
I did a song I gave my birth but kind of
like yeah I'm not there I baked it
he just going to suspect his first real
album whoa and he's got like 73,000
mixtape yeah yeah like seriously like I
remember every week there was a little
bit tape dropping yeah wow that's art
why can't people be like that right see
like little be out like that is music
not once I could play him like his high
but I can respect the movement oh yeah I
can't people do that more like it ain't
for us I hear properties as a pain is
when they were when they were screaming
[ __ ] your button that rolling Lajos that
has every shown up but that had to feel
kind of like it no no cause it was so I
would you stop to be like guys yeah
without positive yeah yeah I feel like
they're just killed him famous I kill I
can't one of these why do they do that
everyone can't wear the Soulja Boy he yo
was crazy is I like Joe Biden glass
sound this is hard but like you know
Papa like he wants to be that guy but
like he wants to play better a message
I'm saying it doesn't know care cuts for
abused you know so that way you're
talking to engage with that interview so
you're gonna give away because I don't
know I because I declare anything
because I wanted to I want to me
but did you think you did you think he
expected you to actually come on the
show and go where nobody expected me to
show up they don't think I was going
time did you talk to him afterwards the
cameras are off you'll have a like
michiel discussion like two seconds
it was just like I mean not me it was
like he told me respect me and if ever
need anything he said he was like and I
was like like even if you don't
I followed on I feel like once he got
that out he's probably more of a fan and
he thought you know after sitting down
with you and it felt like he was I don't
know what he called he was doing but
that's not happens sometimes like Manson
said all that he's actually a cool guy
oh hi baby is calling right now on
FaceTime we should answer this during
the interview he was just here last week
on the show was our bro hey baby
I'm on I'm on a river and I feel like
keV you already know what's up player
Hey so look I want the car you talk
about sound oh you know I'm we're trying
to figure out how to swatch this meter
why do you roam I'll call you when I get
ready this fast amigos be from call you
want girls really go I can't run into
sister baby candy coming soon remastered
version I came I'm on it
oh you are and they're not the best
acronym like of all times
I think company stock baby is is my
favorite brand word he's dealt me not
the SOB babies are Davies right he's got
the best mixtapes out joke everyone send
us is the buyers mix it all right he got
it he got a billboard in Atlanta what
does that mean again he's right about my
house do you want me to say I can't say
it cuz he in words it's damp with sucka
[ __ ] dick ass up thumb thumb and his
other albums called Glocks and thoughts
which is like yeah Italy yesterday I
gave me the night to dude ever yeah you
know cool days though they so any of
each of his lockers lingos awesome so
you gotta like he calls female squids
squealing oh it's so good you get
amazing squeeze squeeze squeeze becomes
cool
so you got collaborate on squid would
you call female TV politically is it a
nice guy
I know English is off the chain are you
afraid that like it might cause some
like QC internatio that's because yes
because you're friends with him I just
had on my q-see last weekend you know
and that's why so I called him earlier
this and call me back I called him there
because I want to you know make sure
everything is good yeah we got squashed
here I'm assuming you have a decent
relationship with offset wheels my
brother come you guys on the same label
relate with my three brothers
Amy I saw baby really really really
cooing I'm saying so yeah you got to
make you I bring the yeah bring it
together get along I don't think they
got to do so it will be hard to push
music it not yet this is I mean you
don't need any beef because I'm in the
middle of it yeah I have nothing did it
are you are you single right now you got
a girl coffee
oh that means he are just gonna talk
about things so think he got to ready
man that's what a player right now man
you know you get the kids heartbroken
under someone I saw I talked about
register business they just cause you
some drama yeah like you wait process
you do the girls are like Nikki last
night at the billboards with me yeah I'm
on topic
oh man you want the Billboard Awards
last night I had a show I would have
been there I gotta ask you um me and my
boys talk about always like we we have a
spank bank right and it's five five
chicks they're like okay you know Jake
about when you jack off to [ __ ] [ __ ]
yes your spank bank you know what I'm
saying like sometimes you're just in the
shower you ain't got the laptop
never happened whoo you pull it up in
your head like you know is it Nikki is
it it doesn't work [ __ ] over the five
who's the five chicks that
that that that that you would like to
take on a [ __ ] Applebee's to 420 day
twenty uh Brianna okay really uh she's
definitely paid back interior
beautiful and I feel like that's very
realistic for you to smash ah that's
nice of you
she'll hop on that way you don't want to
remix joy Crabbie's no yeah okay
like a good little thing I'm not out to
make out she's beautiful
did you guess what flood numbers know
who else we need three more cream or
jacket even no three I always forget the
one that I say the Victoria's Secret
model it really was no I always forget
[Music]
Victoria I see her everywhere now like
in person like on B oh boy oh she's late
not in person I'm not that far
I mean [ __ ] yet the Met Gala man that
that thing is young I ended up there the
who's who loved him I don't know but
saying on even though given some good
any port the you a porn guide you watch
porn ever yeah who's your favorite porn
stars uh and I had until you made me do
artist oh my name is oh I forgot just
what does it look like panic Hispanic
and uh guitar
yes she's big she stick their name is um
Bella Anderson yes brother
wait don't cover anything about the
reporter she's amazed I do this porno
[ __ ] my G yeah I love the lamp he got
his one yeah the other end it like a
[ __ ] out of you go to jail get like a
stallion like a [ __ ] judge when when
she's like it's like Christmas on the
real soon if I go not recently because
I'm engaged now not recently but
Anderson is my favorite porn star and
then I ain't gonna lie I love gianna
michaels I'll just Rio de I'm not in a
white goes yes she's og dynamite goes my
love got the nipple to just blend in
there gay
I [ __ ] like a real contact this one I'm
living to ever before she goes cause
it's like pinky big-nose got2b feels
like that's when you like free porn oh
you gotta go back you got an old lady
I cannot go from our premium tomorrow
free yeah I gotta pee I want a free
chance for pinky so you have a premium
membership yeah bang bro
Oh bang grows and then shout out the
bank big shout out the day though is it
worth it
yes a membership or ninety-five a month
ago today now get out of here
no no you got no year that yeah I got
the wine I invest employee usually I get
that no I don't never but I get the
hacks passwords and usually they last
for about don't worse than me
sometimes they waggle I had a den Broeck
account since I used to I sit back in my
day when I was gone and I used to do it
just for that you know I remember I got
all in this guy he's not real far I have
to own you Oh Gavin you scam it for the
paw report
go first that's um I wanted to ask you
about man probably because I feel like
the scamming thing is getting out of
hand out here it's really getting crazy
he's getting this again lit just get lit
what is your message to the kids out
here that are scamming uh of your caught
don't keep yeah you got caught rank okay
car definitely our car so what is the
change my life get caught oh oh I wasn't
I was going to fill with it so I got I
got turned up in the mall Oh in a mall
shy we was in Florida hmm yeah what part
of for Palm Beach Springs oh man
mmm West Palm Beach West Palm Beach
that's well to rich bogeys I'll pick
those Palm Beach yeah that's crazy man
shoutout to her but it's out of my life
so I enjoy because once I went to jail I
went back to college and I realized I
was not well I had a brazzers password
that literally laughs it's like four
years
yeah me go listen I got it I got to do a
lot of research look at whatever her
name is Ella Anderson
you can I can get a hack password for
bangbros I didn't order
she's in Atlanta okay la I think is
there Miami anyway there they are Miami
wasn't it out here
look we got II not [ __ ] with you even
more ya know it's that we think is not
for me you guys just bought the music
ain't for me but I've been [ __ ] with
you as a person man ever since I was
like I said man I found out you went on
that that opiate wave with all these you
know I think you're a good dude man and
I wish you success with the new album
it's coming out on Friday I think you're
gonna do big numbers I hope so big big
numbers but not then we're just gonna
try again you gonna try it again I got a
shot shows the shopman the new record
x-men's out yep you both is that a thing
I know that you're talking about taking
the chip bowling in the hook
nah I don't all but that's like one of
only dated places I know hmm
take a chill on a date to the ball down
yeah and then watch The Big Lebowski
thank me later it came out in 1997 the
buzz Boston College were all head advice
I understand I was just being born so
let's take about you know my favorite
movie of all time you're gonna [ __ ]
love it yeah so next time make your
hammock how much drinking like trust me
my favorite movie ever after that
browser session you know I'm saying
after that well when I wanted Big
Lebowski
okay consider yachty to building throw
93 baby a throughout after-party